當沖課程 今天這堂是免費教
當沖有一個優點就是沒有風險
沒有風險
你這五分鐘決定要買要賣
四分55秒 你就要下單了
你就要開始當沖了
好 那這樣子就做成功了
當沖的黃金時機
一定要特別把握
幾乎就百萬百重了
9.05分這根K線
會決定你今天勝敗的機率
如果你把這個釋法判斷好
你今天的勝率已經在8成
成功機率很高
因為你是多頭開強強盤
像今天這樣一衝
三萬塊
好神奇喔
我還想把老師綁在我座位旁邊
可不可以
請今天大賺
朱老師
你的年輕粉絲有沒有變多
應該把問題很多
因為我嗎
對
因為年輕人
今年開戶的數量創新高嘛
所以今年的話
我覺得一個狀況很特別
就是當沖的人越來越多了
對 越來越當紅
對 然後我本來以為啊
你不會教當沖
為什麼 因為我連親都不連親
因為我覺得你應該會教大家
看的是比較波段的
可是最近是不是很多人
也來找你教當沖啊
對 對
因為當沖現在也算是現學了
大家都很熱門嘛
都很想
都很想每天去沖啊
去賺點錢
但當沖還是有它的技巧
如果你不是
我們講就是快很準
快很準
如果你不能快又不狠又不準的話
大概當沖就比較辛苦一點
我先走了
對當沖就是要快
因為它時間很短
對
快很準
所以我們今天來破個例
因為趙華過去不想當沖
我們今天要福利大放鬆
我們要拉低年齡層
好
所以今天的理財達人秀
大家敲碗 敲碗 敲碗
你的敲碗 趙華都聽到了
我們的標股在線等
我們的朱家宏老師
要來教大家什麼呢
要來教大家當沖的技巧
等很久了吧
但趙華不得不說
為什麼理財達人秀過去
幾乎沒有教過你做當沖呢
因為我們投資的本質
還是要認同公司的價值好不好
那當沖的話
一定要用錢錢
小錢 錢錢
來試試看
然後學會技巧是朱老師覺得最重要的
所以今天在講這一集之前
趙華比較與眾心長
不要看完就去衝衝樂
看完要先確認你學會沒有
還有用你的閒錢來先試做就好
那我們來看一下
大家最喜歡金庸的小說
金庸的小說裡面有很多
大家喜歡的人物
很多年輕人會不會沒有看金庸
沒關係 趙華一定有看
欸 那句話接得很奇怪
我還真的很愛
我真的很愛 裹小我就看了
因為進攻筆下各個的人物
都有不同的個性
對 很細膩
那你認為在裡面哪一個
比較會轉更會賺
現在是挑附序嗎
OK 我想一下
養過我比較不行
雖然呢 他是姊姊控
給了很多姊姊希望
因為還是可以跟小鮮肉在一起
但後來只剩一隻手了
我覺得不行
她不能這樣抱我
妳還是比較重視外表
國境太默納了
雖然當老公OK啦 很乖
可是生活會很無聊
對 沒情趣
她就去配黃龍那種
瘋瘋癲癲的女生比較好
像我這種兩家婦女不行
這個我愛
真的嗎
令狐充
看起來風流實際深情
對她的小師妹一往情深
最後才去娶了一個
一個更美豔的妖女級的
然後也是私守終身
我喜歡他
好
那我們知道趙華喜歡他
是有原因的
為什麼
因為當聰嘛
叫令狐當聰
他不是吧
他很深情的
令狐當聰 然後日盡萬金
OK
所以我們講當聰就是要
像他一樣任我行
任我行有教他
叫他吸精大法
那我們便利亞叫大家吸精大法
所以我選對人囉
對
跟著他一起沖就對了
其實今年除了年輕人的開戶
創歷史新高之外
還有更可怕的就是史上最沖
現在當沖非常的熱 翔翔棍
而且以前像你看退庸
朱老師一定也聽過
以前很多營業員拉不到客戶
他就每天沖一沖
自己賺那個手續費的退庸
可是現在已經有人是用當充
充啊充啊充一億
可以退10萬
來當做他的生活費
有點可怕喔
當充的交易護數現在是9.08萬
或是創歷史新高
而且老師這個數字不停的往上走
上市貴的當充品
已經來到了35.62
跟38.08
我記得以前當充品20幾%
我們就已經覺得嚇死人了
現在快四成耶
怎麼會這麼的交投熱絡啊
沒有他的原因
因為我們的大凡現在歷史高點
大家報長的人比較擔心
信心不夠
對
所以他想說短線進進輸出嘛
我們講當充有一個優點就是沒有風險
沒有風險
因為你當天就結算了
那要當天有結算掉
有的人很多當天沒充掉
那風險可就大了
那就不再做當充了
我們做當充就要定義一下嘛
你做當充就是當天要充掉
當天無論如何要衝掉
就是沒有隔夜的風險
不要明天早上起來
每骨疊兩千疊
那你就不要一邊神預言
就沒事了
對不對
其實政府今年是蠻鼓勵的
因為有交易量
對 有稅收
所以我們今天不是說不能做當沖
可是請你學好了再來試好嗎
不要一頭熱
那朱老師今天會一個全套的
當沖課程
這個是老師的例子
我們做一個例子
當中有幾個重點先要知道
第二個你這支股票要衝多還是衝空
當中可以做多可以做空
對兩邊方向確認
對只要把方向要確認好
那我們把這個做凱
這是日線
那我們再看
前一天收盤
這是不是一個多頭上漲
對不對
對我們前面教的話
其實他這跟紅K
這跟紅K多頭上漲
然後當天有放大量
那如果第二天
他如果開高的話
就有機會繼續往上走
我們也有講開版很重要
如果開高就容易往上
開高是主力表態
我們來做第二天的多
開高就要做多嘛
那第二天現在我們還看不到嘛
所以第二天要注意第二天的開盤
第二天的開盤
其實我們上一集講K-Bong
還有前幾集講一些
觀察多頭的趨勢都會聊到
來我們看一下第二天怎麼開
好
第二天我們做五分K
我們當中以五分K為主
當中五分K為主
為主軸
那五分鐘裡還有時間做考慮
不會太短
如果30秒、60秒
那個時間就太短
像我們小哥說他20秒
真的無法
好
五分K各位一看就看開了一個紅K
對
開了一個紅K各位看
我們前面也有教大家
這個是不是一個盤整突破前面高點
所以5分K的第一個紅K又有放量
然後大家趕快看前面
我們有交KD
KD是黃金交叉
所以這是我們進場的位置
所以5分K如果我們在快收盤囉
4分50秒囉
4分50秒你已經看到紅K了嘛
那你就去看準備4分55秒
你就要下單了
哦 5分鐘
當你一下單的時候
我們這個時候收盤是172.5
你現在開始當充了
但是我們後面也會教大家
這根紅K不要跌破
所以你也會有停損價
所以你這個地方跌破
也只有賠一個1% 2%而已
那這樣子就做成功了
因為它後面都是紅K往上拉
那你拉到最高
你今天的獲利最高
你就只能漲停板
你不可能再比高了嘛
所以你盤中如果有看到漲停板
你就一定要馬上賣掉
因為你做當中不要忘了
對 一漲停就賣啊
沒什麼好繼續啦
當你賣
你今天這樣子一做的話
你賣掉
假設你買三張
等一下我們會告訴你
為什麼要買三張
所以張數也是一個重點
當然我們做當中
要買三張以上嗎
不是 我們做當中
就是三張
你要有個定額
金額的定額
50萬的定額
50萬來當充
老師你的意思是就算我很有錢
我也不要弄個500萬
我很窮
我也是湊到50萬
因為各位要曉得你50萬
如果你今天賺個3%你就賺1萬5
可是如果今天你停損了
你賠個2%你1萬
那表示我可以容忍這個賺賠
你要有自己的風險的
承擔的風險
那如果說小到5萬塊呢
五萬塊那你就是準備賺一千塊
所以可以嘛 對不對
可以
所以當沖其實是有金額
我們雖然說當沖不要本錢嘛
對不對
但是萬一你今天失敗了
要賠10萬你賠得起嗎
如果你沒辦法承擔
所以你就不要衝這麼多
所以老師其實五十萬以內
我建議大家用五十萬以內
來做當沖
那你碰到一百多塊的股票
你就買三張
大概五十萬
50萬來看你能買幾張
5萬塊股票你可能就50張了
那你今天這樣一充你有3張嘛
所以你一張大概賺1萬嘛
所以你賺了3萬塊
而且就充掉了
講起來很有人啊
難怪那麼多人
所以要來看我的節目
要來看理財當然就不要一直在線的
對你要看這個才知道
但是我們風險提醒一下
當充一定要知道風險
那其實我一直跟大家講
各位在金融商品的操作上
風險永遠擺低一位
即使你做股票也有風險
你看踩到地雷股
不是也是賠得很差
對不對
所以都會有風險
所以我們當充一定要知道
當充就是當天一定要充掉
那為什麼這樣講
因為有的時候我們當充
你看這支股票明天會漲
可是明天已經在高檔了
結果你沒有充掉
結果你留下來了
後天可能就殺你了
等於說我們當沖進場的點
跟買齊長點不一樣
不一樣不一樣
我們是追強嗎
不一樣
所以可能第二天強的
第三天會轉弱
沒錯
你一留下來就糟糕了
第一個你要交割
對
對不對
結果你衝了五十
錢要實際交進去
你當沖是五十萬
你買了三張
剛才那個是一百多塊
對
你一交割就不得了
你明天要付五十萬
是
對不對
所以當沖就是當天買
當天賣不流倉
不流倉
當沖的優點
當然任何事情有優有缺
不然就沒人做了
一定有優點
他的優點就是小資金可以操作
就像我們剛剛講30萬 50萬
基本上你是不要本錢
只是算價差而已 對不對
那第二個多空都可以做
因為我只做一天
我要先賣後買
或先買後賣
就很方便
所以你歷史也可以做
這是他的優點
那我們做股票就不鼓勵你做歷史了
歷史的意思是
也許他現在是多頭
可是感覺明天是會疊
他要回答
所以我做一天
對
這叫歷史
多頭今天高檔爆亮黑黑
那明天就容易回答
那回答我就做這一天
因為如果以趨勢來看
老趨勢就不能做空
對
所以這個一定要清楚
那第三個當然當沖就是
你每天都在說
有時候你做股票報個三五天
還沒有動
還沒有漲
那我當沖就是每天都在做
所以它的效率比較好
但是要記得缺點
當中我相信就不用講
一定要盯盤
一定要盯上班族真的不可能
對 不盯盤你不可能做
那第二個技術分析要很少
學到手才能衝
因為你是短時間就要決定
五分鐘啊
你只有五分鐘決定要買要賣
那我們做股票可以12點以後
慢慢考慮
考慮一個半小時
對
而且賣也很重要啊
對不對 你五分鐘就要決定
我這一根要賣掉了
所以你的技術分析要很熟
第三個就是我們講的
要有果斷的執行率
你要很果斷
乾買乾賣
要手機率
第四個
槓桿的大風險就大
所以各位在操作的時候
不要太大的
不要太大的想像資金
我們這叫想像資金
你說我用500萬來衝
那萬一你今天失敗
兩趴你要賠10萬
所以我們基本上也要知道
它的風險也是很大的
其實我覺得老師你這句話很重要
技術分析要熟練
很多是新手進來覺得他可以衝衝樂
可是相反
老師覺得當中是進階的技巧
你的技術分析要夠熟
你覺得段夠快才能做當衝
我覺得這件事情要很有自知
我可以跟大家講
在股票市場有兩種高手
一個就是做當衝
你一定要
這是高手
所以這算是高手的遊戲了
你如果功力沒有那麼夠
你大概10萬塊錢去充半年
你用10萬塊錢的
你就買一張
你就去充
日式充
去練習
那另外一個高手就做長線
就是我們的骨魚
對
一爆就要爆半年以上的
這個我認同
這個是也是要高手
因為賞富各位
大家自己想
你爆的都爆不住
一般你都爆不住的
所以這兩種人叫做高手
真的做極長跟極短
這都是高手
所以我們當充剛剛已經提醒大家
是高手才能做的
再來就是當充其實還是有一定的本錢
對
本錢的部分
還是有一點交易的費用
費用
而且你一定是手當充
如果你隔天
但是不一樣喔
這個費用就差很多
交割就不同了
對
所以我們先再說明一次當充
所以當充我們都知道
這個都是手續費
手續費不管做什麼充都要
交易稅
當從現在的優勢就是政府減稅
他希望你充嗎
對
如果你用融資融券來充
那還要加利息
還要加借券
券商看他們會有各自的規定
對各自的利率還有他的借券費
融資融券也可以充
你用融資融券去對充
然後你去把他跟營業員講
我這個要今天充掉
他就盤後把你充掉
好 那這樣子我們就知道說
我們來比一下
因為這是你的費用嘛
對 其實費用也不多啦
費用的優勢就會讓
另外一個原因為什麼那麼多人做黨籌
我們來看 假設你買兩張股票
101塊的股票
那今天
這個 這家公司這個價位很久沒看到了
假設啦 你買別的100塊的股票
現在很多嘛 150的很多
假設我買100塊股票 跳一檔
這交易黨嘛
五毛錢
那我買了兩張充
對不對 兩張才20萬嘛
對不對
我買了兩張去充
那我就賺1000塊
可是我的手續費
交易稅減了一半
手續加交易稅800多塊
因為交易稅減半的關係
所以你還賺錢
就是現股當中跟股票
還有信用交易的話
因為股票的話
你還需要資金成本要交割啊
然後你的交易稅也沒有減半
交易稅也比較高
那新聞交易更不要說了
你也是要資金成本
你還要借錢的利息
所以你在跳一檔這兩個
不會賺錢
這兩個沒賺
只有當充平賺錢
所以現在很多都當充
我只要跳兩檔我就賣了
大概領用錢可以賺到
對不對
所以這樣子
所以這是當充的成本上
你比較低
所以你可以多多
而且也不是人人
親手都能當充
因為有一些交易的限制
一系列開戶的限制
如果你已經有融資融券戶
當然就可以充
可是如果你是新手
你要去開戶
那你要三個月以上
而且要有實際成交
成交超過10筆
就是說開了戶
你也有真正的盡買賣
這個金管會當然
正管會也是為了大家好了
當然啦
三個月真的還是菜鳥啦
對啊
你還是要有一點經驗
然後你還要去簽一個這個風險預告書
因為當中它的這個
如果你金額太大風險也很大
那我這邊特別寫一個資金準備
雖然我們理論上是不要成本
但實際上你要有一個
承擔賠損的資金
因為還是有可能賠錢
對你要有一個心理的成本
我大概心理可以多少錢來充
還有就是每日承擔風險的
你可以賠兩萬
一天兩萬 你可不可以受得了
一天兩萬啊
一天二十天
賠六十萬
如果都那麼衰的話
那你可不可以承受得了
如果你承受得不了
那我可以一天賠五千塊
對 或三千塊
來設定進場的金額
那你大概就三十萬充
這樣子 OK
所以還是有一個資金
知道做多是
現股嘛 先買後賣
做空就是先賣後賣
不是 這個都不知道的人
拜託不要當衝好不好
那也不知道怎麼衝
有點嚇人
對
那如果你是支買卷賣
那你就要開一個融資融卷戶
可是有時候你用這個來話
你會碰到停資停卷
尤其要開股東會
那這時候你就沒辦法先賣了
因為他停卷了嘛
所以你就不能
你就只有先賣後賣
你沒有辦法先賣後賣
所以基本上啦
應該很少人用這個啦
一般來大概都是這樣子
就是用當沖
只是買的才卷賣啦
大概是這個概念
另外我們還要注意
不是什麼股票都可以沖
對 這個很重要
因為大家還記得
不是什麼股票都可以當沖
你不要選擇一打根本不能沖
你那邊擺一做
你買進去了不能沖
你要擺明天
擺明天就很嚴重
就很嚴重
所以現在的軟體都會告訴
你要做當沖的這邊就有限沖
而且任何幾乎下單的軟體都會
所以你要稍微注意一下
我這次要做當沖
如果沒有這個現沖
你就不能沖了
一定要認得喔
他有一個買賣現沖
現沖 總之就這樣的字眼
那你就可以做了
誰擋才能做
就可以做現沖了
那我們來看一下
幾個新法要法
再叮嚀一次我們就很擔心
再聊聊
大家不要急
等一下就會進入到實戰了
先把風險聽完
今日是今日必
然後晚上就好好睡覺
安穩
不管賺賠都不要影響你的生活
做每天的新聞也是這樣子
不要影響你的生活
我一直想做股票
千萬不要把生活搞亂
所以你要有自己的風險
第二個他順著第二天的方向做
第二天漲就做多
第二天跌你就做空
然後跟趨勢沒有關
剛剛有特別強調
他只一天的狀態而已
當然我們做當充希望這個股
性飄渴
當然囉
最好盤中可以
扎個五六趴啦
對
所以股性比較活泊的
如果今天開盤太高了
你就不要衝了
比如說剛才我們講
明天會漲
結果一開盤就8%
你也沒辦法
它有漲啊
你猜對了
對不對 你選擇對了
但是你就沒辦法衝
我們在下一次的節目
會告訴你怎麼選股票
好 那這樣子如果當天太高了
你已經沒有獲利的空間
你就不要衝了
因為你衝不好會賠錢
對不對
好 固定金額操作不要加碼攤平
單充就只有幾十分鐘
就那幾根
你沒有機會再去加碼
那疊了更不可以攤平
本來說你容忍5000塊
結果今天賠3萬
那你怎麼辦
所以不要攤平 不要加碼
這個很重要
不要被擋住當充的黃金時機
9點到10點半
其實大家天天看盤
也會知道一開盤的時候最熱鬧
哇 每次國標都一直跳
過了9點半就很安靜了
對 陳教亮也開始比較下滑
換句話說 大家都要休息了
所以9點到10點半是
也就是漲跌最大類段
老師這個是指進場對不對
但是出場不一定對不對
出場當然不一定
進場最好在10點半之前完成我們的布局
但是8 9成的當沖
大概10點半以前就結束了
也就沖完了
也就充完 你也可以休息
下班了
還不錯
充完再來上班好了
對 就下班了
但是這個問題就來了
你9點到10點半這個中間
你就要花很大的精神去盯它了
能不能做 今天可不可以出手
你就要花很大的精神
所以這一段黃金時間
一定要特別把握
那為了你9點或者9點10分
你就能夠出手 又能夠做成功
所以我們今天的重點就是開盤四法
開盤四法進入到我們的實戰教學了
我們先把這個四個方法先定好
等於定理今天的多空
所以你是說用第一根的付分K線
然後但是有四種排法做法
那我們在前面的節目
各位去看那個K線類似
K線類似我又講開盤是誰開的
主力開的 你看我已經背起來了
所以第一根5分K你就知道主力要做什麼
是
所以你一定要等五分鐘
很多人當初一開盤就想進了
對
就很急耶
五分鐘已經很短了 你還那麼急
所以看到9.05分對不對
9.05分這根K線會決定很多的事情
而且也會決定你今天勝敗的機率
如果你把這個釋法判斷好
你今天的勝率已經在八成
所以今天這一集雖然只講這個事法
但絕對只回票價
只回票價 何止只回票價
就跟股票一樣嘛
你一定要選到這一根嘛 對不對
大家在外面如果有上什麼當沖課程
今天這場是你也可以教的
請支持一下我們基因版
對
而且應該也只有我在講
講開盤的這一根
老師是因為我對不對
當然
因為十年的交情
沒問題
我們開盤有四種情況
你會遇到四種開盤的情況
哪四種呢
把這四種分辨好
一個叫強強
強強
一個叫強弱
強中透弱
一個叫弱強
弱中透強
一個叫弱就弱
弱弱就空他
就很弱
你看馬上你就犯了錯誤
馬上我就犯了錯誤
太好了
因為相信很多網友也是
為什麼
你馬上就會犯錯
看到弱弱為什麼不能空對不對
好 我們來先來看
先來看強強
怎麼解什麼叫強強
我們想你今天開盤
就讓你賺錢是不是強
當然喔
然後開盤以後又是紅的
又往上拉是不是更好
賺錢了當然
那就更好
擴大獲利
我開高就賺了嘛
那你又拉
那我就賺更多
所以這根紅K叫強強
我又開高又拉高
紅K收盤在上面嘛
我們在K線大家複習一下
不要忘了開T手高設紅的
所以這根紅K叫強強
可是紅K都可以買嗎
紅K都可以買嗎
如果以趨勢來看就要看位子了
沒有 看趨勢
空頭就不能買
空頭不能買
空頭叫反彈
可是我們是做當沖啊
做當沖也在做方向啊
如果這是多頭
你看到一個紅K開盤恭喜你
而且你今天又準備做多
對不對
那你第二根就要趕快進
甚至於第一根都可以進
這是5分K喔
5分K喔
5分K第一根要開紅的喔
它是多頭喔
那多頭
我們在第二根進嗎
第二根或第一根
第一根也可以
等一下我們去看例子
那萬一這支股票不是空頭
它不是多頭
它是空頭
那我們講的多空是指什麼
是指昨天的5分K
昨天的5分K
因為今天才開盤嘛
那我這個多頭再拿來了
是昨天的
昨天的5分K是多
那今天開高強強
那你就做多
這樣的多頭趨勢中的
強強是做多
那如果昨天是疊的
昨天趨勢是空的
那我們很簡單
昨天是留了一個黑K
那你今天做多還做空
留黑K我應該做空
對啊
所以你今天是做空
怎麼會紅K做多呢
我懂了
所以要搭配昨天的5分K的趨勢
沒錯 今天開的紅K你要準備做空
不要看到牆牆就以為是多
是多頭的牆牆才是多
但是他告訴你他會先反彈
所以我等你反彈完了空
反彈完了反而要再空
因為他可能會再下去
對 因為你今天是準備做空嗎
牆牆在空方的趨勢反而要做空
做彈後空下停
所以大家如果有聽不懂的
前面四集要再回去看
他們都說
很多人都說每集都看三遍
對
可能要看三十遍
尤其你做技術分析要更熟
我們這樣子還在提醒
所以你一定要很熟
什麼叫多 什麼叫空
只是第一根告訴你
它是強的
所以空頭你就不能動了
要讓它彈
彈完了下來才空
這叫等著做
老師這真的有點進階了
如果你這樣子去掌握
我剛剛有講
你做這個第二根
你的八成都會賺到
那你做這一根空
你也會賺到
OK 我們拉例子給你們看
好 來看強強的例子
這個是多頭的強強
我們先看
這個還沒有開盤
那昨天是不是多頭
對嘛 紅K已經是多了
對 我們把它擋住了
老師要幫我們走圖了
你已經會了
好 昨天的收盤是不是多頭
是
那昨天的KK是什麼
5分K沒有跌破 昨天的低跌
並沒有跌破
5分K就是一排囉
這是多頭的回檔
那今天如果開的是紅K呢
強強
紅K又再多頭回後買上漲第一根進場
一路強
這個是5分K所以會有很多根上去
5分鐘就一根
那賺兩趴一定有了
而且如果你今天做多
你去報趨勢你也會
就是你成功機率很高
因為你只多頭開強強盤
對
ok
好 現在來 這個就不一樣了
他也開紅K
好 一樣把它擋住
昨天就要收盤
可是昨天收盤看起來是不好的
一路走低
所以你今天要做空
要做空
結果一開開個紅K
強
那你要做多嗎
我要剛剛老師講的
反彈後再找空
那我們就看他反彈
黑K囉
要囉
要來囉
空
好
喔
好可怕
對
好神奇喔
因為我後面沒看到
對
但老師有講
第一根牆後面會彈
OK
要彈
但是不能彈過這個
不能喝這個
彈過這個就要另做別論
好
那個以後
再研究了
好
彈後空下疊
對
這兩根還是
還沒有疊
疊了嗎
疊了
好
到了嗎
強強分多空
你就會做了
多頭裡面做多
空頭等反彈做空
學會了
但剛剛有講到還有強弱呢
強弱
就是開盤是黑的
他也開高啊
好高興喔
我一開盤就賺錢
結果收盤是往下的
這是強弱
強弱
強弱是黑K
那這樣子來囉
我昨天是多
那這個黑K要疊嘛
所以這叫回檔
你如果昨天是多
你看到黑K 你不要出手喔
不要出手
回後買上漲
因為他的多頭趨勢應該是沒有變
所以他要先回一下
對 因為他是強中透露
他要先疊
他要先把那個弱給疊掉
疊回來的紅K你在買
那如果昨天是空 你今天要做空
那你開黑K不得很好
我要做空啊
結果他開的是黑的
對啊 把他串下去
開靠著黑K就往下坐
你就坐
像這兩個都開高
一個是開高紅 一個開高黑
然後放在多跟空
就不一樣
放在多我們等他把肉給消化掉
等他回檔做多
放在空下去你就空了
太好了就空了
所以你看是不是成功率很高
很高再來看一下圖
昨天這個是什麼
這個很重要
我講技術分析
以後有機會再練
昨天的五分可以看來是
算強啊
對不對 盤整
盤整啊 老師還有盤整這一題
被老師騙了
趨勢不是只有強跟弱
還有盤整 趙豪看了半天
為什麼叫盤整
因為你這個高點沒有過高
低點沒有破低
那盤整的今天的第一根就很重要
對
開低往下就會變空頭
開高往上就變多
盤整要表態
對 那結果是不是開高
開高 那他看來是要往上囉
那這根K線是多還是空
可是這KK是KK那一
對 但是他趨勢呢
趨勢向上
多頭 因為他過高了嘛
對 所以多頭
但是KK啊 所以你不能做
要等著嘛 要等他消化掉
回後買上漲
等到他上漲的時候再買
這個還沒有喔 還沒有過高
好想進場
要過昨天的高點啊
前一根K線
還沒有喔 還沒有喔
過了
可以進了嗎 可以
哎呦
恭喜 我好想把老師綁在我座位旁邊
恭喜 你今天大轉
每一個五分可以出來
老師就一直在旁邊跟我講
如果用當充的觀念看
你今天是大轉 這叫大轉
因為當充最多就到漲停
你還沒辦法
我們後面都會講當充也有目標
兩趴以上 你今天其實是已經到目標了
所以不要貪
強弱的圖在這張是這樣看
我們剛才走圖給大家看了
好 但這個就變成是空方趨勢囉
這是空頭嘛 空頭趨勢囉
那昨天尾巴有兩個紅K啊
那這是什麼
好像他反彈起來了
對 叫反彈
那今天一開
還有 強欸
只是黑黑 強中透弱
對 但他叫強弱
強中透弱嘛
那我要做空啊
那不是很好
你就可以空啊
就一路下去了
唉唷
朱老師你真的要小心被綁架欸
我會
因為我只空散出來
我明天我坐在旁邊
把你放在一個位置
我只空散出來
OK了 看懂了
再來是弱強囉
剛剛是強弱 現在是弱強
沒有 現在是開低了
早上開低盤
多頭區是在那開低
開低是紅的
開低又是紅的
弱中透強
那我又是多嘛
那你已經開始轉強了嘛
那我當然
多頭回檔沒有破低
紅可以上來我就可以做了
就直接做嗎
你要做第二根
沒有陷阱
現在要做第二根
要做第二根
因為你第一根還沒有上來
他只是開低走高
他告訴你這個多頭
一疊就有人拉
我最近看到好多檔這樣的股票
疊下去我不敢碰他
後來又拉紅
那第二根就可以拉
第二根過高做多
好
那如果在空頭就不一樣了
對
空頭這是紅的嘛
所以它會彈
彈
但是因為畢竟是空頭
對 要等他談完再空
再空 OK
然後我們這裡有個空頭的範例
各位看一下
又來了
我們再折一下
再來走圖
這個叫若強
先看昨天
昨天是多還是空
有點盤整的感覺
這下你也好快啊
反應好快啊
盤整
不要再騙我了
朱老師
這是盤整
其實盤整對我們第二天做當充
是最好的
因為他要表態
因為往上就多嗎
往下就做空
往下就做空啊
所以第二天我不知道怎麼開
結果他開低
那我們來看看吧
開好低啊
開低是什麼 紅K
紅K
所以叫若中透強
可是因為一開低就是空頭
所以現在是什麼
我要做空
現在他要反彈
那我要反彈
等彈後空
OK
不要急 剛剛老師有強調
所以你現在紅的不能空哦
紅的不能空 你一空就慘哦
他表態是弱勢了
沒錯
可是因為他
收的是紅的
對 他弱中透強
所以不能馬上去
他會先反彈
所以你不要動
你如果去空就被咬了
你只要停損
我們沒有空
因為老師講開的紅K就不能空
準備了
有了嗎
對 上不去了
好 空他
空 對
謝謝
前進來了
今天令胡松來找我
這樣子嗎 很清楚嗎
所以今天的這個節目
第一個五分K
非常關鍵
因為我們當充的時間很短
所以如果你第一次就做錯了
大概今天你就沒有機會了
對不對
好 最後一個了
最後一個 最後一個了
弱弱K
開盤 開低又黑K
那開低 我是多頭
你又開低黑K 我怎麼做
所以你要等
反過來
等他把弱的消化掉
反彈上來
但是有一個條件
技術分析不能跌破前提
跌破前提你今天最好不要
所以弱弱K還蠻容易
可能就弱下去了
那你今天就不要隨便出手了
不要隨便出手
好 那如果是空頭就太理想了
對
今天我K就下去了
所以趙華說弱弱K在空頭
在空頭
真的就是給他下去了
而且你又準備今天做空
因為你昨天是空頭
你不可能今天要做多
對
所以你今天一定要做空
是
那做空他又是黑K
他又是弱弱
那就太理想
太理想了
所以其實剛剛老師講
這麼多種狀況
四種開盤戰法
然後對應期要多投空投
總共八種
所以八種裡面有幾種
我覺得好像是比較明確的
那越明確你就越要出手
就越容易賺到
好 再來走圖一下
這個盤子
沒有 他變強了
他算是走多
有突破的感覺
這是多頭
那今天開的是弱弱
所以開的是黑一黑
那怎麼辦
弱弱就等啊
就等什麼
等他反彈
等他上擋
等他再上去
不跌了
表示有人再支撐他了
因為你前面低點沒跌破
上去了
最後一個了
我們今天太補了
太補了
因為你第二天一定看不到的嘛 對不對
可是我看這邊一直疊 我明天要做空
那你做空第一根就黑了
太棒了
踹他
我們也有停損 記得要有停損
觀念一定要 不然你這個上來不停損
他一直漲就慘了 你今天要賠很多
所以我們做任何的風險停損都要走
剛剛老師有講到停損
停損當然也可以用你每天可以承受的金額
例如說你每天可以承受1萬5000甚至3000
你要去試算你每天可以承受多少
但是我們會在精英班
來特地來教你怎麼樣出場
因為剛剛我們講的是很多當充的競場的觀念
可是怎麼樣出場呢
我們會在精英班幫你做完整的解析
因為大家可以知道朱老師的佛心了吧
這些課外面你真的是付費
才能上到這麼多
將近快要40分鐘的講解
所以希望大家都能加入基因班
給李才丹秀 標古在線等一個支持
因為後面我們會教你
如何出場 這很重要
所以今天的標古在線等
教了你非常完整的當充戰法
剛剛趙豪有學囉
開盤四種戰法
而且最好怎麼樣
9點到10點半之前
今天打完收工
那強弱弱強強弱弱
八種搭配呢
記得看三遍不夠 看三十遍好不好
把它學起來
希望大家都能在當充的路上
注意風險 完成過利
那我們下次再見了
Bye Bye